hey guys we did it we raised eight
thousand and forty seven dollars for the
Cancer Research Institute I'm so
incredibly proud of what we've done here
blew this that is the total from
directly from the webpage of going fund
me and you guys just did an amazing job
and I'm so happy with what we've done
because it's incredibly important to me
that we do things like this and the fact
that I can keep raising the goal and we
keep hitting the goal each time and
overtaking the goal in I'm just really
proud of what we're doing and what we're
building because when I started out it
took me in almost 24 hours to scrape
together a thousand and now we hit this
goal in just under nine hours and we had
yeah last month's goal of six thousand
in just I think just about the same time
seven hours maybe so thank you all so
much for donating you really are some of
the best fans I could hope for and
exactly what I've always wanted in the
channel of mine so thanks again I'm very
tired but I'm gonna get some rest and I
hope you all have a good night all
plenty of videos ready for tomorrow so
thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye